Hello and welcome to Rawkode live. Today is
Clustered.
I am going to, with the help of
some guests, fix some broken Kubernetes clusters today.
First, we've got a little bit of housekeeping.
If you are not subscribed to the YouTube
channel, now would be a really good time
to do that. Click subscribe, click the bell,
and you will get notifications for all new
episodes of Rawkode Live. I will do my
best to bring you the best cloud native
learning materials on the Internet. All you have
to do is watch and enjoy, hopefully.
Also, if you wanna chat, there is a
Discord server. There's over 400 people in there
now talking all things cloud native Kubernetes and
everything in between. So you can check that
out at Rawkode.chat.
And also starting today, this is the July
1. We are taking on a new sponsor
for clustered and that is Teleport. This was
the easiest decision I had to make because
I love Teleport. We have been using Teleport
and Clustered since the very beginning as a
great tool and I'm excited to share it
with you all today. So if you wanna
check that out and support the show, go
to Rawkode.liveteleport.
Now, let's fix some broken clusters.
Today, I am joined by Marek and Abdel.
Hi there both. How are you doing today?
Good.
I always say that and then throw it
out and forget I've got two people and
then they've got to say who's gonna talk
first. But, Marek, can you please do the
honors, introduce yourself and tell us a little
bit about you?
Yeah. So my name is Marek Counts. I've
been doing cloud native Kubernetes things
for a couple years now.
I do a little bit of YouTube in
myself, not nearly as good as Rawkode, but
all about learning about computer science and
and
Kubernetes.
So I'm really excited to learn more on
this show. So thanks for having me. Awesome.
Thank you for sharing. And, Abdel, please introduce
yourself and tell us a little bit about
you.
Yeah. Sure. Hi, everyone. Abdel. I go by
board Abdel on Twitter. I work for Google.
I specialize on everything, Kubernetes and serverless and
all these fancy, fancy buzzy words.
I am also core leading cloud native community
back in Morocco. I'm actually based in Stockholm,
Sweden, and I have a podcast. It's Iran.
You could just follow me on Twitter to
find all of that. And when David invited
me to actually come fix some clusters, I
was like, this is exciting. Because in Google,
we don't fix clusters. We just delete them
and create them again. So
so that's gonna be interesting. Yes. It's gonna
be a whole lot of fun, and I
will make sure to include links in the
show notes to both your YouTube channel and
your podcast, both of you. So I really
appreciate you being here, and I'm excited to
see what nasty things you have got in
store for us.
Okay. Let's get started.
We're starting on cluster 33.
I can't believe there's 33 of these already
and this
is Maddox cluster. So I
am going to
join
the
control plane node. This should start a session.
Abdul, you should be able to join through
the teleport interface.
If you can just give me an echo
hello to let me know that you're here,
I'll type echo hi first.
Let me know when you're in and then
we'll get set up. Oh, you're already in.
That is super awesome. Yep. Alright. So let's
set up our kube config.
This is a kube a d m cluster.
We're gonna use the admin conf
and of course we always need our alias.
Alright, Abdul.
The tradition on this show is you get
to run any command you want to see
if we have an API server.
Fire away.
Alright.
Let's do that.
Let's check pods and nodes at the same
time.
Okay. So we have some pending NGINX stuff.
Postgres is pretty much dead.
Your app is pretty much dead as well,
and we have three nodes not ready. Lovely.
Alright.
Let's have a look, I guess.
Yeah. What what do you want to start
fixing?
Well,
I'm curious about the NGINX nodes. I don't
think I left them there.
So but I'm gonna say they're not important
for now.
We've got stuff stuck in terminated.
Yeah. I don't know.
I guess it's because I mean, I guess
the postgres is terminating because the nodes are
not Yeah. We don't have any worker nodes.
Right? Everything there is not ready. Correct. Yeah.
So the Postgres is I in but it's
not running.
I did leave a read me on there
with just, like, a little bit of info,
but feel free to debug it as you
like. Yeah. We'll take a look at the
readme. I'm curious why you've added control plane
rules to my worker nodes,
Mavic.
Okay. I I had to have some fun.
Okay. Most
most control plane components are rising. API server
is running. Kube proxies are good. DNS is
down. Yeah. That's gone.
Okay.
And then the packet stuff is also down.
Let's start with Postgres. What do you think?
Well, do you wanna will we take a
look at this read me? I think that
we shouldn't look at the list of things
you did, Marek.
Sure. Go for it. Go for it.
My mistake.
Was that supposed to be there?
My mistake. Go look at it.
Okay. Let's let's look at it. List of
things I did, the read okay. Do you
want to read the read me? Yeah. Let's
start with the read me. Just
Alright. My broken cluster.
I hope you enjoy.
Blah blah blah.
Okay. So we don't have any nodes which
are allow us to schedule workloads. I think
we kinda work that one out.
And we need to get that working on
the default namespace.
You have broken each node in a unique
way. Well, thanks for that. That's always fun.
Alright. We even got little difficulty levels. So
Yeah.
Will we start with worker easy and then
see if we can get work it work
it up?
Yeah. Let's do that. Sure.
Alright. Okay. So I am gonna jump out
of this effect.
So node 58 g and k?
Yeah. I'll jump off of that and I'm
gonna do t s h s h root
at this node
or even at symbol.
And you should be able to join us
on that machine.
Alright. I've done echo hi. Let me know
when you're there, and we'll see what we
can do. Yeah.
You're so you're so quick at this. Alright.
Should we check for a working kubelet?
Yep. Let's do that. Do you want to
do it? Yeah. Sure. Alright.
It does appear to be running, but we
definitely have some errors
here.
Yeah. Let's let's check the logs.
I'm sorry. Don't know.
Let's check the log, I said. Yep.
Journal
CTR.
I should have added just the tail.
Alright. This is not very helpful.
Stop it for now.
Connection refused. Ah, it's not We've no container.
The potential there. Okay.
Let's check that. System
CTL
status.
Container d.
Container d looks like it's good.
That
looks suspicious.
The docker
d dot sock.
Where where is it?
The third
log line.
It says address slash run slash docker slash
docker d dot sock. Uh-huh. Yeah. Okay. That
sounds good. Yeah. I wouldn't expect to see
that. So perhaps it's being misconfigured.
Yep.
Where is the config file for container d?
That's a a good question. So, I mean,
we can definitely look here, but I don't
think we'll see anything
and etcetera,
which means we're probably gonna have to do
a cat container d
and start working our way through any drop
ins that we see here,
of which
I don't see any.
So let's do a just a find. I
mean so I think that the the it's
at etsycontainerd.com.
I I need to wait. I'm looking for
a config file.
Okay.
Come on. There's also a very cool container
d config dump command as well, which I've
used in the past.
Uh-huh.
Container d. Really? That's cool. D dump? Yeah.
Pretty
pretty
verbose. People keep doing bad things with container
d and alias and images, and then making
my day really bad.
I think this is our problem. It's here.
We have to fix this.
Yeah.
That's not that's not right. I think if
we fix that path, that should be our
easy one fix, and hopefully, our node gets
back online.
Alright. So I'm gonna go into the file
and just look for
run,
and then we should be able to fix
this. Right?
What?
What's going on in the session? I'm not
sure. I'm gonna suggest that we just escape
and quit out of this.
Mhmm.
Oh.
Hello?
That sounds good.
I didn't do that. Just so everyone knows.
That was not
This is this is either Teleport or the
streaming software. Right?
It'll be maybe the command line interface for
Teleport. So for modifying this file, I am
going to grab
a web browser and see if it helps
just in case.
Or
we can just edit it and we show
people what we changed.
I
guess you were seeing the same as me
though. Right?
No. On my side, I will see it
properly.
Ah. Yeah. Okay. If you just if you
just fix it, and then we can cat
the fail.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
So
That's funny. It is.
Yeah. Sorry, people. It's coming. Just give me
one second. I am not good with Vim,
so
I have to and it's a slash run
container v slash container v dot.
Slash
run slash container d slash container d dot
sock. That sock. Right. Yeah. Okay. Cool. So
You didn't have to tell us you were
bad at them. We wouldn't have known.
Okay. So
this is what we changed, the address of
container d.
If you so when I scroll, it doesn't
scroll on your side? No. No. You can't
scroll on my terminal. But I'll I'll try
and keep up. Don't worry.
That one
was set to slash run slash docker slash
docker d dot sock. So I just fixed
it.
So you should be able to
if you can restart container d.
And then we'll need to restart the kubelet.
True. Maybe.
We'll see.
And then let's pull up your journal command
from earlier.
That looks good.
That looks good. Yes. It does.
Let's look yeah. So that was the cubelet
the logs of cubelet. Right? Yeah. Yeah. That's
coming back on later. Okay.
Yeah. And it's it's able to talk to
containers, so it should be fine. Do you
want to exit oh, no. You are on
the control plane node. Maybe you want to
do get get nodes and see if it
was fixed. No. Sorry. It's a different node.
Yeah. I dropped off, but let's jump back
on the control plane because I think we
should see
we should see that healthy.
Yeah.
I'm gonna have to start adding this to
the profile when I spin up the clusters.
Alright. Let's see.
Easy mode when. There we go. Alright. That's
fixed. Okay.
Do you want to check the README file
again? Let's see what's the next in the
difficulty level.
It is v x four. Let's go for
it.
Let's go. Alright. Alright. So t s h
s s h we're at go.
I'm
gonna apologize
here because
this one also has the
the cubelet problem. It just has stuff on
top of that. We've already seen the cubelet
problem. You guys fixed it or the container
d problem. You did that on every note?
Come on.
Not on every node. Just on this node
as well. And that was my bad because
that's not fun.
So that's why I'm telling you. So you
can just fix it real quickly.
Alright. So it's the same problem with as
the previous one. Right? Yeah. I'll let you
if you wanna jump in and fix that
and There's more.
It's just that is one of It is
the same problem and then other stuff.
Yes. And this was my apology. I shouldn't
have done the same thing.
It was late when I was doing this.
Was there with a config dump too? Yeah.
That is a great command. We love that.
Oh.
People are enjoying listening to Marek laugh.
And
just install Nano. Come on, Khalid. We're not
gonna install Nano.
Somebody was suggesting to use c. If you
can give us the c command, it will
make our life easier for the next node
because he did the same he broke it
the same way No. No. The third node
does not have any of this. Just these
two. I accidentally did it. I
thought that I hadn't done it, so I
did it again, but I was doing it
to a different node, and that was my
problem.
Okay. Okay. That could look good.
So
The Kubernetes is especially
not verbose.
No?
Or maybe just me?
Yeah. There was no logs there, I guess.
Let's check the logs then. I am a
big fan of journal CTL. So I
just love seeing the different parameters that everyone
uses with journal CTL.
Alright. Okay. Uh-huh.
Container. Uh-huh.
Don't see anything there that gives me cause
for concern yet.
Okay. Then if you think it's fine, I'll
just do a quick f to see
what are the latest.
I don't know. Jono, I forgot with Jono,
how do you do the tail? How do
you get the tail?
Dash dash last and then a number, I
think.
Uh-huh. Okay.
Well, it looks good. I usually just do
f u.
Oh, yeah. You do f u l. Inverse.
Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. Cool.
That looks good.
Yeah. But it couldn't be this simple. Right?
Perhaps.
I don't know. Try scheduling something on it.
Well, we don't have to schedule something on
it. We just need to get our workload
scheduled on the cluster.
The existing pods that are in pending states.
Do you want to quickly jump on the
control plane node and check if it's good?
I bet it's not. Yeah.
So
TSS,
HSR. I'm just gonna leave this one open
because we're gonna need access to it.
And I'm fed up type and export already.
So that's definitely gonna add you to my
global profile on every future cluster.
I apologize for making you switch back and
forth so often.
No. It's part of the fun. So if
I was using the web interface, I have
multiple tabs. I was just trying to avoid
doing that on the browser. Maybe I'll just
start running both.
Alright. So that
node is not ready yet. So if there's
kubelet, there's definitely something wrong.
What could this be if it's not the
kubelet?
Can you
rerun that command
with the dash o y? Let's check the
network configuration.
Maybe he changed the internal IP or something?
I'm just speculating here, by the way.
Well, we would see a message from the
kubelet that it couldn't reach the
API server.
Okay. Yeah. That makes sense.
Yeah. Let's let's double check these logs.
Think about Okay. What needs to be running
when
for it to be healthy. There's some things
that should be running, generally, I think. We
need the queue proxy as well.
Yeah.
It looks can you check the
status of the queue proxy on the because
I think it was unscheduled,
or was it was it running?
This is v x four.
Okay. Let's see. One of one. We have
Cilium, we have Cilium Operator, we have Hubble.
Postgres is actually oh, no. That's terminating. Oh,
no. We did these are all terminating.
Cilium's okay.
How about I don't care about. Postgres, yeah,
we'll fix it eventually.
Kube proxy is running
and healthy.
Okay. The Kube proxy is good. Then and
and the and the
Cilium components are good?
Yeah. Only Hubble appears to be broken which
we can ignore. But yes, we have the
Cilium and the Cilium operator running okay on
this machine.
So I'm gonna suggest that we try
describe a node and see if we have
any events or warning.
Sure.
Okay. So it looks like it can't speak
to container d.
I was trying to pull images
or do image garbage collection.
You wanna double check our container d configuration?
Yep.
I can.
Can I extract an iTerm tab
split to tab? No?
Alright.
Slash run slash container d slash container d
dot sock. That looks good to me. But
is that binary file
where it needs to be?
Yeah. It is there.
It's
suspicious.
What's that suspicious color?
Okay.
It's a symbolic link.
This isn't
this is not a binary. Right? This is
a symbolic link.
What am I saying bullshit here?
It
doesn't look like a symbolic link.
No. It's not. But it's not
We get the same color on the control
plane node, so I think it's okay.
And when I try to run it, it
says permission denied.
So let's
let's try running a CTR
image pool
nginxdocker.i0/engine.
Yeah. Container?
Uh-oh. I was gonna say container d is
okay. Did I get that wrong?
Or the top level repository.
Right?
Library.
Yeah. I know. That looks good. Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. Container d seems okay.
So it's not Container d.
So if we look at the describe again
Oh, come on.
Export
alias
describe.
I guess this is maybe just an old
error then. So let's look for something else.
Let's see if there is any memory pressure
or disk pressure on the node. You have
those under the conditions.
Well, it's tainted with no schedule
and no execute,
but that might be because it's unhealthy.
Yeah. I think so.
Network unavailable.
Yeah. But it's false. It says is running
on this node. It's the conditions. Right?
Cube so the Kubelet RPC error, that was
eleven minutes ago.
And then the newer one is Kubelet started
Yeah.
Kubelet started Kubelet started Kubelet. Okay. Okay. I
was like, a Kubelet started the Kubelet? Like,
what's
what's funny?
Okay.
What
else could it be? Normally, a node would
not be ready if we had no
networking.
But since the Kubernetes is able to reach
to the API server, it means it's working.
Right?
What are some of the other ways that
a node goes unhealthy?
So the component Kubernetes is not reachable.
Maybe the CNI is broken, but Cilium seems
to be okay.
Will we try restarting Cilium and see if
it actually reschedules?
Maybe
That's good.
I know, but it's not Yeah. We'll need
to do it on the control plane. So
I can do
pods all white.
Correct.
Was it b x
four?
And then delete pod.
Dash n.
Cilium.
Bye bye.
Oh, almost.
And I should have forced it.
We don't need to wait on that. Let's
see if it still shows up here.
Oh, it's stuck in I am gonna force
it. Okay.
Grace
period
zero
force.
It's not starting was unexpected.
Yeah. It's not coming back, though.
Yeah. Because the node is stuck. Right?
I I jumped with you into the session.
Yeah.
Just give me a I I just want
to check something.
So the node that we are talking about
is this one.
Because your output of describe looks translated on
my side, so I wanted to see it
on the terminal directly.
Actually, we do have a problem.
What do you see?
So
I don't know why, but here. See?
Memory pressure, disk pressure, cubelets stopped posting node
status
node status unknown. Right? So if these conditions
are not
met,
then the node
well, the the EPS server will not flag
the node as ready.
And then it won't schedule anything on it.
Yeah. Correct. So the the Kubelet is not
posting something
to the node,
which is making me think that you have
screwed up the Kubelet configuration,
which we can check-in
the ETC Kubernetes
no. Slash slash bar lib
kubelet
config.
Did you
if you modified in your file, did you
keep any backup at least?
Nobody ever leave. I did, but not of
this one.
Not of this one. Okay. And
we can fix this one. I can help
you with this one. Hold on. Hold on.
You just can't done, mate. Hold on. Hold
on.
Why do you have a memory available 500
gigabots here?
Is this port correct? One zero two four
eight? That doesn't ring a bell for me.
Hold on. So that 500 gigabytes will say
that it hard evicts any pod if you
don't have 500 gigabytes. You're on the right
track with that one.
Okay. So that's not good. Yeah.
You can delete that one.
Oh, thanks, man.
Actually, I I cheated a little bit because
while you guys were talking, I went to
the cubelet config on the control plane node
to see what's going on there. That's a
cheated that that's good debugging.
We like that.
Okay.
Let's see. I restarted the cubelet now
on this node, and it should
be a general CTO.
It looks like it's good.
Okay.
But let's go back and check this
node status.
Yeah. It's still not ready.
There might have been something else in that
file.
Yeah. That's that's what's going to be my
last my next one. So let's check
this file, what's going on there.
I'm sorry. We cannot do from history.
I'm just comparing to the file, but I
don't want to compare. I want to see
by myself if I can spot something.
The health check port is good.
No suggestion that might just be iTerm that
is struggling there, so I'm gonna find out.
I'm literally now just comparing the two files,
just to be very honest.
No. Good.
Keep diffing them.
CPU blah blah blah.
That's good.
Okay.
Yeah. Make this better term. Hold on. Hold
on. What is that run once?
That's not good.
Sorry about that.
Yeah. Run once is a not very known
configuration
that makes the cubelet just run one time
and then ends.
That's doesn't look like a very useful configuration.
Where's the run once? Where did you see
that?
It's
you can see it here.
Run once through.
Do you see it there in your screen?
Oh,
got it. Yeah. Like, I commented out and
restarted the cubelet.
Alright. So
And
now I believe we should be good.
Okay. It's ready. Good.
So who don't? What's what's
the run once flag for?
One runs allows you to run the cubelet
once. It will do its thing and then
shut down, basically. So it goes on not
ready anymore because it won't accept anything more.
That's what it does.
What's that for?
Sounds like or not
Like, four year or no. Not four years.
Maybe
two years ago, there was actually a person
that had gotten this in their configuration,
and it caused me no amount of grief
before I found it. So you guys are
awesome because I would not have found it
that fast.
So look at if you open the if
you open the terminal where we have the
shared session on the worker node, do you
still have that one?
Mhmm. So we can show the people on
the livestream what's happening. So run one's true.
I commented that out. Right? So this is
pretty much what we were talking about
where Mark explained. And then there was these
two lines
a little bit up that says memory available
500 gigabytes. It's literally the third line from
the top as we see it on the
livestream.
We never actually got to see this in
action because the run once was working. But
with the eviction of hard, it's going to
actually kick out pods it doesn't have at
least 500 free gigs of memory. Usually, this
is a very small number. You want a
little overhead, a little room, little wiggle room,
like 200 megs.
I see. So you wanted us to find
the run ones, fix it, and then stumble
across the second one.
I thought the run well, there's actually a
third one that you guys haven't found, but
the cubelet will be working.
But
we can come back to that when you
find that things aren't being scheduled on it.
Uh-huh.
There's more surprises.
Yes. But for the most part, you fix
this node.
So what's happening?
What's the
what's the node name?
V x four.
Yep. So
we have a bunch of stuff that are
supposed to be running on that node that
are
We've got an admission controller,
potentially. Unexpected
admission error.
Okay.
Okay. Sneaky.
So what do you want? Do you want
to continue working on this one, or do
we move to the next one?
Well, let's do a quick check for that
admission error.
So
let's try validating
webhook configurations.
Validating.
Okay. I'm mutating.
Failing that, it could be in a kubect
config again
as a static.
Yeah.
Can you can you maybe describe one of
the pods that says
eviction error? Like, that Cilium operator pod maybe?
Mhmm.
Executed error while a computer recover from admission
fee.
Preemption. Not very helpful.
So we we
can take a look at the
Kubernetes
manifest and
the Kube API server.
My Vim is not gonna work, is it?
Oh, no, it seems okay. Oh, no.
I'll do it in key.
I don't know how to list this. Okay.
I'll just join a new one because I
don't know how to join from the command
line yet.
So what do you want to check?
I wanna see if the
admission controllers on the Kube API server are
set
and the file here. So we can do
manifests
then cube.
Wouldn't those affect other nodes though? We're looking
at something that's just affecting this node.
Yeah. That's what I'm thinking.
If if the admission controllers were misconfigured, unless
if they were, like, a custom programmed one,
which they are not, I didn't do that
much,
they would treat all the nodes equally.
Okay. Let's jump onto the hard node then
and see what we can work out before
we
Alright. We move on. Okay.
So LS.
I'm gonna do SSH onto root at and
this is zed p
r.
Yep.
It is
kubelet.
What?
I don't know.
There's no telling me Ketty isn't a good
terminal,
but
I'm just maybe I'll I'll I think I'll
just use the web interface.
You know, fun experiment, no using the command
line.
Okay.
So what was that error again?
No. Even from the web interface.
Okay. Thought I thought it was my my
terminal, but, okay, it's not. Right. Cool. Did
you mess up the terminal? No. It's my
cutie. Alright. I'll let me pull up the
web interface.
Alright.
Okay. You wanna join this new session, please?
I'm waiting for it.
Okay. So if we run the status on
the Kubelet, we yeah. We've got we've got
messages here. So
Request cancel while I is this IP address
of the of the
of the,
sorry,
of the EPS service. Correct?
Let's find out.
1477549.
6 7?
Yeah. Yep.
Failed to ensure, and it's getting a timeout.
So maybe
maybe it's
some sort of,
like, something that blocks
this node from existing out to the API
server because it's getting a timeout issue.
Yeah.
So maybe a simple thing would be just
to ping that
IP and see if it will respond.
Oh, sorry. I'll let you type.
Oh, oh, oh, just make it sure. It
should be one
four seven dot
I know that I'm copying it. Well, I
should just copy past it. Just bear with
me.
67.
Yeah. You're right.
6443.
Okay.
I'm expecting to see an okay here.
This is the Halsey port of the
the API server or maybe API. No.
So the node is not this node is
not able to reach out to the API
server on that IP address. So maybe
Can we ping it?
No. And, no, we can't. Can we ping
the Internet?
But you SSH over public IP. So, yeah,
the Internet actually should work.
So I guess for IP IP or something?
Exactly.
Yeah.
I'm really bad at reading active rules, by
the way. So I'm just
looking for, like, a very quick hint.
Yeah. Well I should have put four or
five stars on this one. Just
I apologize.
For dropping mark block in terminal local net.
Okay. No. There are nothing. Right?
I don't see anything. So there's a
this is a Cilium cluster.
I wonder if we'll get any Cilium host
networking policies.
You think so?
I mean, we can definitely check. So Cilium
has has the ability to use eBPF
to modify
the networking,
but we can do a separate Kubernetes.
Let me just set this up again.
K k control.
And then we can do k get
host
net poll. Is that right? Nope.
I don't know how the Cilium host network
policies are.
Yeah. So we wanna get
Cilium.
I kinda wanna just Class provide network policies,
but that would make sense.
None. And then there's Cilium
network.
Oh, okay.
So it's not that.
You can you guys are
for educational purposes, you guys are, like, right
on the right path.
This is why I said four or five
stars because I kinda went off the beaten
path of what the right this is where
you should look.
If it's something that was happening.
At Cilium. At your container run at your
container networking
solution, in our case, Cilium, hundred percent, this
is probably where it would be coming from
or DNS.
Uh-huh.
Well, DNS, no, because I tried to do
a ping from the worker node on www.google.com,
and it worked. Right? You already proved DNS
was working. Yep.
So it's not that.
So I'm looking at the serial configuration
and
control plane node to see if
you messed up with that. Let's
see.
Dash
dash o YAML.
Okay.
Yeah. But if the Serum configuration was broken
on the control plane node, it would affect
everything.
Right?
That's probably not it.
People are suggesting it's always DNS.
I don't think it is DNS.
It's it's not DNS this time, but you're
most people would be right to to question
DNS.
I don't know how often that breaks.
So I did a trace route from the
worker node toward the IP address of the
control plane node,
and I could see that the node actually
is able to get out. So it's able
to get to the gateway,
and I I believe the problem is on
the receiving end, so it will be on
control plane side.
Right?
Sorry. I'm I'm I have a background in
networking, so I'm reasoning.
I do not. So I I'm loving this.
I'll let you
do this.
Okay. So Well, I don't know what to
do. It's gonna be obvious, to be very
honest. I I just flex it a little
bit in my note my notebook knowledge. Okay.
No IP table. I'm
gonna just make sure we have
no firewall.
I mean, I run a status. I'm assuming
it's not running though. Yeah.
No. I thought that would be too easy.
You guys are better than that. I like
easy. Just Easy's good.
That was the other two nodes.
Guys, blew through those.
So
what else could this be?
Is
uh-oh.
I'm trying to think of a good hint
for you guys.
So you were really, really, really, really hot
when you were talking about Cilium and eBPF.
Like, you were on fire.
I hope there's not an eBPF probe running
on this machine.
Hold on. So if we look at all
the pods
and we do a dash o white here,
And then we grep on
the node
that we have.
So the z p blah blah
is Cydium running here. The Citium operator is
running on both nodes,
so that's good.
Let's check. I want to check the logs
of this thing.
Post the this. And Which machine are you
on? Sorry.
I'm on the control plane node.
So this one is not outputting any
oh, come there on the logs.
But so the two Cilium things that run
on
does not have any logs?
So I I see a a binary running.
I kinda highlighted that, but I don't know
if you've seen. But there's this BPF filter
running,
which to me looks
rather suspicious.
What is
BP filter?
You want
I mean, I'm gonna suggest we just kill
it and see what happens.
Go ahead.
Oh, three six.
Followed by taping.
Do you wanna try that ping again?
Yep.
Sorry. Give me a second.
Still not
pinging.
It's six seventy six. Right? What what what
is that IP address again? Just to make
sure that I'm not pinging the wrong one.
Having killing the program may have made things
worse to be fair if that was the
malicious. No. In fact, it's running again.
Okay. Let's find this rogue system d service
or Kubernetes pod.
Let's see what we've got running in the
cluster.
So in
in
light of educational,
there is a thing called a BPF tool,
which you can use to, like, examine BPF
apps if that's what you're digging into.
I'm not sure that it's installed on this
machine.
That was just a greater
for everybody out there watching if you're
digging into these things.
But this was running on the control plane.
Right?
It was.
I think there's something on the control plane
That's got an blocking
traffic from that node.
Am I right, Marek?
You're close.
It's
actually on the worker node. It's on the
worker node.
Yeah.
So I I think we're close to time
here. Yeah.
So what I did is There's Python port
blocker.
Yes, sir.
Actually,
just
actually, just deleting that doesn't fix the problem
because it actually loads the BPF module
that Python
does,
which is that filter c. So you could
actually go and check that out if you
like. It's just an eBPF program. All it
does is it goes in and
it reads each line there. Yep. That was
it.
So it takes every single packet. And if
it's from the API server, if the source
was from the API server, it rejects it
and throws it out.
It drops the packet.
Which is why when we did the trace
route, we got out, but we then never
got anything back. Okay. Not get back in.
You never get the request because the request
is dropped by or the the response is
then dropped by this. This is never going
to happen in production
and was just a fun eBPF
demo.
Okay. Jabbarred. See you later. Okay.
Sorry, guys.
In the interest of time, and
I wanna do
wanna do cluster.
Did we grab all like,
did we get all the issues there, Mark?
Are you happy?
You didn't fix the deployments, but that's fine.
We didn't have time. Yeah. Just I I
I wanna make sure we have enough time
for both clusters.
So I I deleted the scheduler,
and so there is no scheduler in the
static pod manifest. So how kubeadm stands this
up is all those are static pod manifests,
and they're those manifest exists in a static
folder. And so I just deleted the scheduler.
Now I did back it up, so it
was there. If you guys found it, you
could have just restored it. But, anyways
Alright. Awesome. Alright. So no pod would get
scheduled right now because
there's no scheduler.
Alright. That was the last thing. And a
nice
assortment
of problems there for us to tackle.
Fun,
kinda. It was so fun. You guys were
you guys were fantastic. Alright.
Thank you very much for that. Let's see
if
Abdele has been nicer to us.
I'm not very sure. Alright.
I'm gonna open a session on the control
player node. Please join me and echo something
when you are ready. I will export a
kube config
alias
kube control.
And I will give you the honors of
running whatever command you wish to check that
we have an API server.
Yeah. I agree with the comment there from
Navin in the chat. Abdel, you were fantastic
debugging for that. Very well done indeed.
Thank you. Yeah. I I a % you
guys rocked it.
Although I am adding no eBPF to the
rules in future. So that's no UTF characters
and no eBPF.
I do have a tendency of people making
new rules when I join challenges. So this
is alright.
Not entirely.
DevOps direction did a challenge, then he made
a new rule after I I did that.
So I apologize, guys. I do like to
have fun,
and, hopefully, that was fine. I didn't mean
for it to be horrible.
Alright.
Let's see. We have a control plane. This
is looking good so far.
Yeah. We have one working worker.
One was scheduling disabled, and something broken.
Oh, so the theme of my challenge that
even if things seems to be working, they
sometimes don't.
Those are the worst. So let's
yeah. Yeah.
Let's actually just describe this work. Actually, let's
look at the pods.
Let's see.
Yeah. So we have some InvictD.
What ones are those running on? So I'm
okay.
Let's see.
So there are a few things. There are
some nodes that are broken. Oh, actually, all
of them are broken. They have to be
fixed.
If I could rate them from the easiest
to the more difficult, it would be four
w g l m
followed by well, maybe g h p seven
k is first one, four w g l
m second one, and then the last one
would be the more difficult.
And
but, like, I think you will fix the
nodes very quickly. It's what I what I
would like you to do is actually try
to get the workloads up and running.
Okay. Okay. So you're more interested in that.
Let's
Okay. Let's fix four w g l then,
and then we'll take it from there.
I've created a session. Feel free to please
join, and then let's start the let's start
some debugging.
Oh, okay. Sorry. I was still on the
control plane. Let me pull up the new
session.
Alright.
I'm there.
Alright. So if we're looking here,
is up.
Memory pressure falls. So we're seeing disk pressure
on this node.
Okay. So you did that describe on a
node.
Yep. And we're seeing some disk pressure. So
something's causing disk pressure.
The terminal went all funky on me.
Yeah. So the failed disk something is causing
failed disk.
So let's try oh, okay. So the limits
are zero. It maybe it's not necessarily failed
disk, and they just configured the cubelet
funkily
in a weird way. It's not really a
word.
Well, looking at the disks on our worker,
our root partition is at 99%
saturation.
Although, there's still 2.5 gig left,
but even just
looking at this
So how would you figure out Okay.
How do you do the iNode thing?
So you can do if you want to
see which folders are full, you can do
a d u dash h
dash dash max depth one
max dash depth one
or like that. Yeah. And it should be
able to tell you where do you have
a lot of stuff.
Alright. And our directory.
We got some chunky looking files in here.
Yeah.
Those hundred gig files.
You wanna just well, we just delete?
I think that I I don't think that
those are useful for anything. Not that I
know of. Yeah.
If we delete those, that should hopefully
cure up that. I'm looking over the describe
here to see if I see if anything
else that was
yeah. I think that should clear it up,
and then I'll just run a describe again
and see if that
Yeah. That's looking
much better. Hopefully, that removes the desk pressure
warning then.
Yeah. It looks like that made it You
you guys pretty much got it. You fixed
it. So the goal actually of this exercise
was to because I get a lot of
times, we get people asking us, can we
just install random stuff on the clusters? Like,
can we actually use the nodes of Kubernetes
to do other shit? Right?
And, obviously, the problem there is that if
you install things on a Kubernetes node that
is out of the control of Kubernetes itself,
it would know about it. Right? So the
kubelet has a configuration to clear up the
logs,
to rotate the images, etcetera, etcetera on a
periodic
schedule, but it does this only in few
parts of the file system. So if you
would deploy something in slash root or in
slash OPT, it wouldn't know about it. Right?
It's like if you're running a VM on
a node,
which I thought Pretty much. Yeah.
Yeah.
A VM outside of Kubernetes.
Cool.
Is there anything else that Kubernetes is controlled?
Anything that's having to be running through Kubernetes
itself.
Alright. So we have this next one that
has scheduling disabled.
Check
out why the Yeah. Go for it.
One second. My sessions got all little bit
weird. It just resized the window a little
bit and it it tweaks it.
Okay. Just drag the corner away and we
put it back in.
That that does fix it. Perfect. Thank you.
Alright.
So we want to
describe this. I think describe is a generally
good
way of
Sorry. Yeah. Sid is asking where should I
install my crypto miners if not on the
control plane?
That's a good one.
No crypto miners here. Thank you.
Okay. So you've described
do we see a reason for being unscheduled
about?
It could just be tainted that way. One
second. What's let's see. Yeah. There's definitely got
a tint. I mean, we can try removing
it and see if it gets added back
or we can
Oh, one second. We have AppArmor enabled.
Who enabled AppArmor? Figure properly.
What? Nobody's allowed to enable AppArmor.
Come on.
AppArmor is enabled. I
did not enable AppArmor. It is there.
Alright.
Let's see what we'll choose.
Let's check out its labels.
This looks fine.
I guess we could also check the cubelet
logs here.
Which machine are you on? Oh, the actual
node. Right?
I'm on no. I'm on the control plane
right now. I might jump to the actual
node and check or if you wanna
I'm just looking through the describe right now.
CPU looks good. Memory
pod limit.
Version.
The version is right. Same as the rest
of the nodes.
No, Kevin. Never gonna happen.
We'll never be using an episode with Red
Hat Linux and SE Linux.
Okay.
Alright. Did did you get the
logs of the cubelet?
Nope.
Okay. Let me I can jump over there
and get them. That's alright. What machine was
it?
I don't know.
G g h p. Yep.
Alright. I have opened a session on g
h p. Come say hello.
We'll do a journal fluke.
I mean, I guess maybe we should just
untaint it
or remove the unschedulable and then go from
there. Yeah. I'd say we remove it and
see if it comes back. I think that's
a pretty good shot. Yeah.
You can just click here at that node.
Really should copy the name. I know.
Tense.
Remove the unschedulable as well.
Fixed.
Yeah. That that I was just so that
was the last node they wanted to to
screw up. I didn't know what to do.
It was just cordon then.
So you could I mean, you did it
you you did what should happen. You could
just do a kubectl
and and cordon, and it would just go
back. Cordon.
Okay. Yeah.
I didn't think it was a cordon because
they never seen anything in the events to
suggest that it was cordoned. I thought an
event would show up there, but I guess
not.
Alright.
So let's tackle this last one.
I'm going to do a let's do a
cube describe
on the control plane there.
Yeah. Go for it.
Which ones? One second. I gotta go reconnect
to the control plane, I think. Remember to
join so we can see it on the
Yeah. Screen.
I'm not nearly as fast as a bill
at at rejoining
these. Alright.
So we have our notes here. Let's go
ahead and
describe this one.
Alright.
So
let's see. It's not ready.
We have unknown.
Networking is not available on the node. This
is a big
red flag. It does say Cilium is up,
though.
I so that what pods are on this
node.
That output is extremely confusing, by the way,
because when it says network unavailable falls, it
actually means it's true.
Oh, that's right.
Because it's a double negative. Unavailable. Yeah. I
get it. Yeah. Okay. Whoever does the double
negatives, that's that's you're
right. Okay. But we're unknown on all of
our memory. So this could be a
bad configuration of the cubelet like I had
done,
or it could be
the health endpoint
could also be busted.
Let me look through here. It looks like
it's reporting
how much CPU
and memory
it has.
Non terminated pods, it has Cilium up, default
cluster,
cube system.
I've opened a session on that node if
you wanna Okay. Poke around.
Yeah.
Which node z x r six q.
So I guess let's go ahead and check
the cubelet logs so we can do
Nope. There's another.
Alright. So
Kubelet nodes not sync.
Unable to write.
So that almost looks like you when you
see these unable to write, it could also
be like an etcd error when
you try to write a resource. I don't
think this is because etcd usually is a
cluster wide event.
But sometimes when you get unable to write
things,
it's etcd. But I don't think it is
in this case because it's this node specifically.
Yeah. I think you might be I think
you might be right. Yeah.
We also got another tell. Error message just
above above it, which says eviction manager failed
to get memory. It got failed to get
summary stats,
failed to get node info,
nodes have not been ready. So, yeah, I
don't think our kubelet is actually speaking to
our API server potentially.
In fact, at the very end Yeah. That
big wall of text, we have a timer
as well.
So So let's just check the firewall.
It's what is it? The it's Ubuntu has
the super easy firewall that I can never
remember. It's not firewall d. It's u f
w. W f? Yeah. U f w.
I don't know.
Yeah. Don't think there's Oh,
are root. So
And you can try firewall d as a
usually work. That's usually there as an alias.
Yeah. So I don't think there's a firewall.
Okay.
So if there's not a firewall,
they could have messed with IP tables. That's
I'm not very good with.
Let's see.
Dash capital l will list all the rules,
then we can look for drops.
That's about as much IP knowledge as I've
got.
But Abdel may have given himself away earlier
by telling us of his networking background,
so I think we might be able to
It's
more simple than that. You're
on the right path, but it's more simple
than that. Alright. So we have rejects here.
Yeah. We're rejecting TTP anywhere.
So, I mean, if we ping google.com,
this should fail. Right? No. It works.
I mean, those IP addresses you are looking
at are 17226.
Those are internal IP addresses. So RFC ninety
eighteen.
Oh, okay. Right. They're only rejecting to these
internal
internal ones.
Alright. So we just need to remove these,
which if I knew the command for that,
I would do that right now.
We can try a flush and see if
they go away. I think if you do
that
And then restarts
kube proxy.
If
you do it, the queue proxy will just
recreate those, by the way. It's a controller.
Right? So it does look reconciliation loop.
Well, or maybe after you. Okay.
So let's
so did he put something? I I just
did an all let me look through the
namespaces here, make sure he didn't hide anything
in the namespace.
Okay. So that's the we have the Cilium
not connecting.
Outlook. Middle will be
So he's using Cillium or
a controller to do it.
Don't see any Cillium network policies.
I also don't see anything
that's running here that would do that.
I'm gonna restart
kubelet and container d and then
check the logs of the kubelet. Let's see
what happens. I'm curious to see if we're
still gonna see that time out.
Yeah. It looks maybe.
Alright.
One second. Let's check.
One second. Let me join the session over
here. I am enjoying this very much.
What did you say? I apologize. You broke
up a little.
I said as networking nerd, am enjoying this.
Oh, that's good. That's good.
Alright. So we have the idea that our
IP tables are getting screwed up. And let's
check our services actually.
Yeah. We got this drop all anywhere anywhere
on this.
I mean, that looks bad to me. So
something is rating. It's not it's it's not
of epidables. I'll just help you. It's not
epidables.
It's more simple than that. It's more simple
than that. Yeah. More simple.
I don't want you to go into IP
rules, firewall rules, loophole. No. Wait. I
mean, is it just the IP address is
wrong? Let's
let's see.
Seems fine.
Wait. We could check the
check the
the Someone's left as a backup.
Oh.
Very nice. Nice backup.
I didn't want you to leave you hanging
there. It just have this configured endpoint
for the API server.
So if you edit the and remove the
one in one sixty eight, it should work.
Well, you were right. It was simpler than
that. You want the honors of fixing our
IP address?
Sure.
I want you to get to the next
one.
Alright.
An interesting note here, if you ever type
reboot,
so system CTL reboot,
it will actually just reboot your machine,
not the service that you type after that
because it takes it as a bad argument,
which would then say now.
Anyways,
fun story. I've done that too many times.
Alright. So now you want us to get
on to the next one.
Yep.
Well, he just said I did this before
and he's right. I actually just removed the
s from HTTPS
and nobody
noticed it.
Oh,
do I need to add that back in
then? No. No. No. No. No. No. No.
Was a different episode. It's just a flashback.
Oh, okay.
Maybe I think want to check if your
notes are up.
I was gonna say, I don't think we're
scheduling stuff though still.
So
Alright. Let me check. Confirm that.
Yeah. So we still have evicted pods here.
Let's just go ahead and describe one of
these pods.
But that's just an old replica set, and
it's a Vexit.
I think it's just not been cleaned up.
Like, it does look like clustered is running
and Postgres is running.
Alright. Let me do this.
Let's see. Yeah. Scheduled.
So here is the challenge.
So here is the challenge for you guys.
So when you deploy an app into Kubernetes,
if you want to expose it to be
able to reach it, you have to create
a service. Right? Service.
Alright. So you wanna create a service to
expose memory? Yeah. Yep.
Well, we could always check that our current
services have endpoints.
Okay. So we we should have a postgres
and a clustered service. Do wanna see if
they are looking good?
So we have
none.
So let's go ahead and look at
our Postgres here.
That's good. Alright. So we have app selectors,
Postgres.
Let's see. Here's the IP. We don't have
a type on here, do we? It's cluster
IP.
But I think the important thing here is
the endpoints has a value. So I'm curious
to see do you wanna do the same
on clustered?
Sure.
Or yeah. Do it do the same on
clustered and try to scale it up and
see if that's actually what's broken. So you
you kinda got into what could be broken.
So Right. So that
IP corresponds to one to the pod which
already exists of clustered. Right?
Right.
And you already are
putting a port on there. Yeah.
So scale clustered up,
Let's say two replicas, for example. Let well,
let's try, like, let's try upgrading the image.
It's rather than scaling it.
That could also work. Of course. Yeah. Because,
like, you know, one of the things we
wanna do here is modify our deployment
to get v two.
So
If it's just hitting okay. Sweet. You have
a different I was gonna say if it's
just latest, it you can't actually do that.
But this is gonna still point to the
same endpoint.
It should be a new hardcoder.
But
there there is a new pod. You go
ahead and do get
Alright. I'll I'll do as I feel said.
Let's scale up.
Because that that looks okay to me. Right?
But Can you But this is the problem
here. One second.
Can you rerun the What were saying, Abdul?
White.
Yeah.
And see So this is the IP addresses.
Yeah. Yeah. This is what the problem is.
Been updated.
His endpoint's not being updated, and so
it's not going to do this. So we
need to go in and edit the service.
Or fix the controller manager, maybe. Do you
think it could be disabled?
I've
actually never hard coded endpoints
into a service. Usually, I use a selector
label.
There there should be a selector label, though.
Right? But there should
be a selector label. So let me look
for that.
I don't I don't remember if it was
there.
Yeah.
My
I'm assuming if their service hasn't been updated,
then Abdul has been a bit of a
mini and disabled one of our controllers.
And I'm looking at him to see if
he's got guess. Got a tail. Like
No idea. Alright.
So we do have an app selector.
The endpoint's not being updated. This this is
an old update. This isn't any either of
the new ones.
So
So my
I'm assuming if we come in here. And
look at the manifests.
I wonder if he's been kind enough to
leave it back up. No. Not this time.
But look at the cube controller manager here
has a list of
controllers.
You
see that?
Yeah.
The endpoints.
Sneaky.
So if you do a minus on the
controller, it means remove one of the controllers.
Right? Yes.
So the star means all the controllers except
the nondefault ones. The nondefault ones are the
token cleaner
token cleaner and the bootstrap
validator or something like that. And then if
you do a minus on one of the
controllers, it just basically removes that controller. It
doesn't run it. So I remove the endpoint
controller,
which is what You can do the same
thing.
Mhmm. Yeah. No. You can do the same
thing with labels with the minus and just
removing the label.
Yes.
So the reason I didn't leave a backup
there, it's because
I struggled with it because I didn't know.
If you just get that file copied to
something called dot old dot backup, the cubelet
will still pick it up.
It wouldn't pick up the files and start
with a dot, though.
So you could have Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. Dot
back. Oh, yeah. I could I could have
done that. Yes.
Alright. So now we need to restart.
Yeah.
You have to roll out your
do a roll out on the We have
to restart the cubelet, though, first. Right?
No. The cubelet will detect that failed change
to roll out the new controller managers. I
think we'll just need to modify our
deployment,
and then the controller rollout rollout. Yeah.
Okay. So we just need to restart
this.
Yeah. You can use whatever whatever method you
want.
You're too nice. I normally do cube delete
pods dash dash all.
Which I know is a horrible, horrible way
of doing it, but it's fast.
Oh, wait. Did I
Yeah. You just missed that l
and clustered. Yeah.
Sweet.
Now we should be able to
describe the service, and we have all the
endpoints listing.
Very nice. That was a good one.
And, yeah, I I actually really like that
one because of the
the educational with the dash minus there. Let's
see if there's anything else here that's broken.
Yeah. I'm going There is one more thing.
I am going to
just on my local terminal dot port forward
and see if we can hit our application.
That's fine. Let's grab this one.
Looks like we're gonna get a timeout.
So I suspect our clustered application cannot speak
to Postgres.
Well, we didn't scale Postgres or anything, so
anything that had a bad service,
right, would need to be updated anyways.
Right? Failed
to connect the database and we've got angry
face.
Alright. Go for it. How do we fix
this?
Alright. So I was just looking at everything
that was up and running,
which is quite a bit.
Let's actually get the logs from
the database, see if if there's anything wrong
with the database.
I'm guessing that it's the database service.
So Postgres here, it says it's running.
I always use git with logs.
Yeah. We all do it.
They they might as well make git and
logs like
just like an alias.
Yeah.
Do you wanna check the So it says
surface and make sure the IP addresses match?
I wonder if we need to
do that, you know, what we did with
the clustered one. Okay. Yeah. K. Get pods
dash a,
not
dash o y.
So its IP address is this one right
here, and then we're going to do 4156.
It's just Postgres,
I think.
Alright.
Why did it re oh, I I misspelled
it. There we go.
There we go.
So
external IP, cluster IP address. Yeah. This is
let's describe this service.
Oh, if nothing else
this is correct.
yeah.
What what's the IP address that
he could've messed with the IP address?
No. It's always DNS.
I was hoping you don't see it.
It's
always DNS. Okay.
Yeah. Probably. That's because earlier when we were
when me and David were stuck at one
of your problems, everybody in chat was saying
it's always DNS.
So
you screwed with DNS.
You wanna check what's running in the cube
system namespace?
I'm now starting to doubt whether that service
was called Postgres or PostgresQL.
Like, I wonder if he's just renamed it.
Oh, no. Or we just had no core
DNS. Look at that.
Or or no core DNS. Yeah.
That would be a problem. Wait. Wait. Did
you leave us a backup?
That's a lesson for you folks, how to
easily screw up DNS in Kubernetes.
I'm assuming by a desired zero, this it
may just
be scaled down,
you think?
We could try scaling it. Let's let's do
that. I'm good with that.
Okay.
Let's let's do three since we have a
three node.
And you'll need the namespace.
Yeah.
Let's see. Well, it's they're not running yet,
but
it says three of three ready. Hit the
refresh. See if your database works.
I
don't think so.
Alright. Well, we do have core DNS
running.
We have three pods running. Let's check some
of the logs from core DNS.
Did you leave the queue proxy command running
while you were scaling up and down the
queue port forward command while you were you
were scaling up and down clustered?
That might be your problem.
It definitely still seems to be timing out.
Do you wanna exec into one of our
pods and try cluster DNS and see if
it's working?
Yeah.
I was just looking at the logs. I
don't see Yeah. Cloud DNS never logs anything.
Yeah.
Yeah. Well, it didn't fail.
But yeah. Okay. Sure. We can exec into
I guess, we could exec into the clustered.
Does it have fashion in I don't know
what's installed in these. It's
shit. What is it? It may be Alpine
or maybe Scratch. We're about to find out.
We can just run
we could just run a
You ran NGINX earlier, right, I think?
Alright. I did. Let's let's
Yeah. There we go. Let's jump into there.
I'm pretty sure that's got bash available.
Go for it.
Don't know what complete.
Curl.
Oh, let's try normal DNS.
Yep. And
Kubernetes.
It looks to be working.
Do we have NC? No.
Can
you crawl Postgres?
We're getting into the end of this, and
there is only one last thing
that you have to figure out.
Yeah. The name of the DNS package across
different operating systems. That's the one thing I
need to figure out because it changes every
time.
And tools,
DNS tool. It changes
per version.
It'll
take
come
on. Maybe around that app to get update.
Did you do an update? I did.
I just never remember the name of the
package across Ubuntu,
Debian, Dms utils. Dms dms dash utils.
I I did that.
I thought I tried that.
Yeah. Maybe it's not dash.
Yeah. Alright.
Let's take
Postgres.
No response. Have to do defaults.
No. Dot dot defaults. Because otherwise, it would
be It's
in the default namespace.
Oh, there we default, it should find it.
Yeah.
Okay. That resolved. DNS is working.
Oh, no. It didn't. Because this is
oh, no. It did. It did.
No. It did. That's your IP address of
the DNS or the Kubernetes API.
So
he said there's one last thing for us
to find out. We gotta
figure out something else that's broken.
Yeah. Okay. So I I would okay. Just
to help you out, it's something that shouldn't
be there.
Something that shouldn't be there.
Yes.
Is it this file right here? When oh,
wait. Where am I? We're still in the
container. Yeah.
Oh, okay. Yeah. Thank you. I was like,
what?
Nice tip from Waleed using plus short with
big Oh, that's the
that's just the
backup of the cube control manager.
So something that shouldn't be there.
There's metal l b cube system.
Let's see.
Packet.
Wait. What's this packet packet cloud, man? Is
this I I don't know what's this supposed
to be in this system. I could check
Yeah. That's just the the Equinix metal CCM,
but it's not been renamed. So it it's
it's okay. We trust it.
It's hard for me to know something that's
not supposed to be there when I'm not
necessarily
sure what's What's confusing me is that
our application we can we can browse to
this is still a DNS error, which we
know is not to be true. So
either that pod isn't getting DNS
or it's just some Probably
probably put differently.
So your clustered application is not able to
reach your database, but your NGINX application was
able to resolve DNS. Right?
So Okay. So we need to take a
look at our deployment for Clustard because he
may have modified it.
The deployment or the service could have
the wrong ports
exposed.
But no. Clustard can't even resolve
the DNS, but our Nginx pod did.
Even if the DNS Are you sure that
it cut okay.
Okay.
Let's okay.
Put it a different way. Let's say that
you are a security cautious customer. Nope. You're
trying to
block
the hell out of everything that you don't
need, and then you fucked up when you
were trying to do that.
So are we talking about, like
did you go in and modify
the
capabilities
or the
the permissions for this pod?
Oh, depends how No
cluster role binding for it? No. I'm saying,
like, did you go and, like,
give it a a role with no permissions?
No.
Something is there, but it's just misconfigured.
Okay. So something
Good catch.
Cheeky.
I like I like David. They just delete
stuff. It doesn't care.
Very nice. You can't delete.
You deserve that one. Yeah. I put the
top policy to block traffic for the clustered
app on egress. So even if you can
talk to it, it's not able to talk
out, so it could not reach Postgres.
Very nice. I checked the Cilium network policies,
and I didn't check the standard cluster policies.
So for the sake of
knowledge sharing, there are two things you have
to keep in mind. Kubernetes itself has a
network policy, an upstream API part of the
Kubernetes code.
Right?
That network policy allows you to implement network
policies on a cluster,
but
it doesn't come with a controller. So we
basically when you install Kubernetes, you have to
install something that will make those network policies
happen. So Calico or Serium or anything like
that. And most CNIs that exist on the
markets, they have some sort of integration, and
they allow you to either use their own
CRDs like the case of has
has network policy, which is an object. You
can either use that to define the network
policy, or you can use the upstream network
policy
API,
and then Serum should be able to read
that and enforce it or or whatever c
and I run the cluster. Right? And that's
done for portability.
If you have a cluster that runs on
one cloud provider with network policies, you should
be able to take it out and put
it in a different cloud provider. As long
as they have network policy
plug in, it should just work.
There you go. Alright.
Thank you both for
ruining my day.
Some evil evil breakages of both clusters there,
and
thank you for also spending a little bit
of your day fixing these clusters with me.
It's been it's always super knowledgeable seeing what
people do to these clusters and the way
that they think and the way that they
debug and it's just an absolute pleasure for
you both to join me today. So thank
you very much for that.
Thank you for having us. I hate both
those clusters. I gotta say that those are
just cruel. Network
policies, DNS.
You're just bringing out the worst in everything
here.
Hey. Know that's what I'm doing with DNS.
Alright.
Thanks to everyone that watched as well. Thank
you to the sponsors Teleport.
We use Teleport today to debug this. Make
sure you check it out using the link
in the video. Do either of you have
any last words before we finish up for
today?
It's Thank you, dude, for that cluster.
That dude, that that was a fantastic cluster.
I really appreciate it.
We should do this again sometime.
Yes. We should come up with more interesting
ways to break things. Well, it's funny that
you both mentioned that because next week is
the start of cluster teams, and I would
love for you both to bring a team
for the team edition if you wish and
get involved that way as well.
My team versus your team?
It's a rematch.
I can't promise you that's how the schedule
will go, but if you both wanna submit
teams, we'll catch up afterwards anyway.
I know we're a little bit overtime now,
so I'm gonna let you both go. But
again, seriously, absolute pleasure. Thank you for joining
me and I hope hope you both have
a wonderful day.
Thanks. Thank you, folks.